Next question today.
David, if Trump does delay deal the election,
can you tell me definitively who becomes president?
I've heard Nancy Pelosi.
I've heard Chuck Grassley.
I don't really understand.
OK, so this came up briefly in a voicemail
earlier this week.
But let's go through it again.
If Donald Trump delays the election enough
and again, I'm not debating here whether he
can do it, how it could be done, how much
he would do.
I don't want to do that stuff because there's
all sorts.
You know, the electors have to vote.
I believe it's in the first half of December.
And there's other dates and elections are
run by the states.
These are 50 state decisions more than they
are anything that Donald Trump would do.
So let's skip that piece for now.
But let's imagine we get to January 20th and
there has not been an election.
Trump doesn't stay in power.
Trump stops being the president.
Now, when you look at the line of succession.
OK.
It would go from president to vice president.
But Mike Pence also would no longer be vice
president.
Well, then it would go to the speaker of the
House, Nancy Pelosi.
Well, if the election in California doesn't
happen, she is no longer elected.
So she's no longer speaker of the House.
So it would skip her.
So eventually it would go to the Senate pro
tem.
Now, currently, the Senate pro tem is Chuck
Grassley, a Republican, because Republicans
have the majority in the Senate.
But the problem is that 35 Senate seats are
up for election in November.
Of the hundred Senate seats.
If those 35 elections don't happen again,
we're assuming none of the elections happen.
You might have some states do the election,
but not enough to select the president.
But let's skip that for now.
If those 35 Senate seats end up being open,
you now only have 65 senators.
And that means that the Democrats would have
a majority because Republicans have far more
seats to defend in November than do Democrats.
So if none of these 35 elections happen, Republicans
lose more seats than Democrats.
You then have no president, no vice president,
no House.
But you have a Senate made up of the 65 remaining
senators who are more than 50 percent Democrats,
meaning Democrats get to select a Senate pro
tem who becomes the president until this is
resolved.
Now, historically, again, this is our best
understanding producer.
And I have been researching this.
This is our best understanding.
Historically, Senate pro tem tends to go to
the most senior senator from the party right
now.
That's Vermont's Patrick Leahy.
However, it's conceivable that if the 65 remaining
senators knew that by electing a Senate pro
tem, they were essentially selecting the next
president.
It's conceivable they would pick someone other
than Patrick Leahy.
But that's the scenario, as I best understand
it today.
That would determine who is president.
If we don't have a presidential election in
November.
Now, let me go back to what I said when I
commented on James Clyburn earlier this week,
saying, I think Trump is going to, after he
loses, use some kind of emergency to stay
in power.
I believe that our coverage of that possibility
needs to focus around the idea that the mere
suggestion of delaying a federal election,
which has never happened, is a despotic, authoritarian,
dystopian nightmare.
The now that we I was asked the question,
what exactly would happen?
I've answered it to the best of my ability.
I don't think that's where the focus should
be.
The focus should be that Trump even floating
this idea is completely outrageous.
We vote in this country.
We figure out how to do it.
States are expanding absentee ballot access,
universal absentee voting, as I'm calling
it.
And we're going to have an election.
And Donald Trump is going to either win or
not win and things are going to happen on
the schedule they're supposed.
That has to be the default conversation once
you start engaging in what would justify delaying
it or what would be the mechanism for delaying
it.
Academically, it's interesting, but it's problematic
when it becomes a corporate media dialog,
which only legitimizes the idea at its core.
So that that's my take on that.